KIM: Hey, everyone.
Thanks for coming today.
It's my great
pleasure to welcome
Carey Nachenberg to Google.
Carey's a leading cyber security
expert and a chief architect
at Symantec, where he was
notably one of the authors
of Norton Security.
He was named a "Computer
World Magazine's"
"40 under 40, 40 Innovative
IT People to Watch,"
and awarded the "Wall Street
Journal's" 2010 Technology
Innovation award for his
innovations in the security
field.
Carey is also, in mine and
many others' humble opinion,
one of the best adjunct
professors at UCLA
in the Computer
Science Department,
where he's been teaching
for over 15 years.
He's here to talk
to us about Stuxnet,
as well as his new
techno thriller,
"The Florentine Deception,"
which I can certify
is a terrific read.
And Carey's also
donating all proceeds
from the book to charities
benefiting underserved students
and veterans.
So the book is supporting
look a lot of good causes.
And with that, I will
hand it over to Carey.
[APPLAUSE]
CAREY NACHENBERG:
So I'm going to talk
to you about Stuxnet today.
Now Stuxnet is a little
bit old news, actually.
It came a number of years ago.
But it's still a
fascinating story to tell.
And it actually is
tied, in a small way,
to my novel, which is there.
You can see "The
Florentine Deception."
So before I begin,
let me just give you
a brief introduction my novel.
Hopefully, I'll get
you excited about it.
So the book is called the
"The Florentine Deception."
And if you're an edge of
your seat adventure fan,
you like reading adventures,
sort of Tom Clancy,
or let's say "National
Treasure" would
be a good example of
the type of adventure,
if you like techno thrillers
that get the details right,
because most techno
thrillers don't, if you
want to help underserved
children and veterans,
then this might be a good
thing to take a look at.
And also, if you want to see
how Iran gets even for Stuxnet.
Because as you know,
Stuxnet attacks Iran,
and Iran does play a
small role in my novel,
or maybe a larger
role, as it turns out.
It's called "The
Florentine Deception."
It's available in
all major formats.
You can find it online.
And as Kim mentioned, I'm
donating all of my proceeds
to charities that either
benefit underserved students,
helping them get access to
charter schools in inner city
areas, as well as veterans.
So providing training
to students and veterans
in high tech fields, and then
placing them in internships.
OK?
So scholarships, charter
schools, training.
And so far, I've
donated $4,500, and I
hope to donate a lot more.
So let me give you the
30 second elevator pitch,
then I'll talk about Stuxnet.
So what would you do
if while rummaging
through an old
computer-- you know,
poking through its files-- you
discovered a clue to a lost
treasure?
Well, if you had any
curiosity at all,
you'd dive head first into
a hunt for that treasure.
And that's exactly
what Alex Fife,
who's the main character
of my novel, does.
He dives head first time in
a hunt for this treasure.
But what Alex finds is
that what he's hunting for
may not be a treasure after all,
but in fact, something far more
dangerous-- a tool,
that in the wrong hands,
could be used to
decimate the internet.
And when I say decimate, I mean
really, literally permanently.
So it's a little bit
adventure, and a little bit
to techno thriller.
And hopefully, you'll
take a look and enjoy.
But let's go on and
talk about Stuxnet.
Now, let me just
preface everything
I'm going to talk about here.
There are certain things that we
know for a fact about Stuxnet.
And I'll tell you
when I know things.
There are certain things
that are supposition.
In other words, I've
never been, actually,
in a centrifuge enrichment
facility in Iran,
so I'm going to basically
speculate about certain things.
And there's certain things where
I'm going to just make them up,
and I'll tell you
when that happens,
so at least you'll know.
So to my knowledge,
this is Natanz, Iran.
If you've heard
about Natanz, Natanz
is an area where they
do uranium enrichment.
So this is where they're
spinning uranium,
and we'll talk about that.
This is an overhead photograph.
I've never been here, so
I'll take their word for it
that it's actually a
satellite photograph.
This is a lie.
These are not
Natanz' centrifuges.
These are a Google image that I
found on a Google Image Search.
But these are
centrifuges that actually
are used to enrich uranium.
And they spin uranium gas.
I think it's uranium
hexafluoride gas.
And this is how generally
they're controlled.
And this is true.
So what we have is a
whole control system
which includes a Windows PC.
Guess what?
[LAUGHING]
You're already
starting to laugh.
Windows PC.
And these Windows
PCs run software
from SIEMENS called
STEP7 Software.
And STEP7 Software is a
development environment
for developing software
to run-- basically
control programmable
logic controllers, which
I'll talk about.
So you have a Windows
PC that's connected
to some special
hardware call a PLC.
And there's a PLC.
And the PLC is a
programmable device
that is used to control
industrial systems.
Industrial systems could
be a roller coaster.
It could be a popcorn machine.
It could be uranium
enrichment centrifuges.
OK?
And in this case, that PLC is
going to control this uranium
enrichment.
Now, that controller is
not directly connected
to centrifuges.
What happens is that
controller is connected
to a set of communications
processors, which
are basically routers.
That's a fancy name for
a router that basically
controls groups of devices.
And those routers are
then connected to things
called frequency converters.
Now, what are
frequency converters?
Well, basically what they do
is they take wall frequency
of, let's say, 120
hertz or 240 hertz,
and they convert it to
potentially different speeds.
So 2,000 hertz, 1,000
hertz, and so on.
So frequency converters actually
change the frequency in order
to run on devices at
faster frequencies.
And finally-- and this is
what's most interesting--
are these centrifuges.
So centrifuges are big
tubes, aluminum tubes,
that spin at very high rates.
I'll tell you a little bit
later, but very high rates.
And what they do is
they spin uranium gas.
Now, there are two
isotopes of uranium
that are basically
found in nature.
And one isotope, the lighter
isotope, if I'm not mistaken,
is the one that's used
in actually producing
nuclear fuel in bombs.
The other isotope, the heavier
isotope, is actually not used.
It's a sort of the
default isotope.
I So what they do is they
spin the uranium around
in these tubes.
And the heavy uranium
goes to the sides,
and the light uranium
stays in the center.
And they basically
have, if you will,
a pipeline whereas
a lighter uranium,
gas is filtered to the center.
It's then piped into
the next stage, which
then does this process again.
And they basically successively
enrich the light uranium gas.
And that's then used in order
to produce fuel for bombs.
OK.
So that's how they're
all connected.
And this is how
they're isolated.
Now this is a little
bit of speculation,
but this is how we understand
that things are isolated.
So we believe that there is
a research network-- OK, yes,
there are a little green men.
They're the plastic figures
you used to play with as a kid.
There's a research network,
and that research network
is isolated from the
uranium enrichment network.
And we think that
people were maybe
connecting to the internet,
doing research and so
on, on the research network.
There's a firewall
out to the internet,
then we have some guards
in little green uniforms,
and they're literally that size.
They're literally about
a couple inches tall.
And then, they then would
separate an air-gapped network,
which is where the uranium
enrichment process takes place.
And when I say
air-gapped, I mean
that we believe there were
no connections probably
in and out of the two networks,
between the two networks.
OK?
So you get an idea.
Now, this is probably,
this is a lie.
But I googled Mossad programmer,
and this is what I got.
So I basically made a
nice like, card there.
That's probably not
the right guy there.
But anyway, I got this picture
from Google Image Search.
But this is probably
a Mossad guy.
And let's just say he's
a Mossad programmer.
And we're going to
assume for the time being
that Israel is somehow involved.
But maybe, maybe, they weren't.
OK.
So what this guy
wants to do-- OK?
What this guy wants to
do-- I don't know his name.
He wants to introduce this
digital time bomb, if you will,
onto this computer right here.
That computer is the
Windows PC, because that's
where he wants to start
going, because that's
the easiest thing to get to.
So he wants to introduce
that onto that.
OK.
And how exactly is
he going to do this?
How is he going to get this
onto an air-gapped network?
Because remember, that
network, that network
that runs those centrifuges,
is totally isolated
from the rest of the internet.
So how is he going to get
that onto network with those?
Well, first of all, the
threat has to spread its own.
OK?
So there has to
be some autonomy.
The threat has to
spread and actually
be able to reach that
network on its own,
because they're
probably not going
to be able to get a spy
to sort of bring it in.
Well, they might have.
Until it discovers
the proper computers.
So the threat has to
keep spreading 'til it
discovers the proper computers.
If it discovers the
wrong computers,
it's not very useful.
I can't disrupt your
computer or my computer.
It wouldn't be very useful.
Where it can then disrupt
the centrifuges-- so then
it's going to disrupt
the centrifuges,
all while evading detection.
And Stuxnet is an amazing
threat, because it did all four
of these things well.
I mean, it's amazing.
OK now, there was
no rocket science.
There's no sort of alien
technology involved
in what's Stuxnet does.
Everything is regular
computer science
and things that anybody here
could do, given enough time.
But what's amazing is how
they got everything right.
So let's talk about
each of these phases.
I have to move
around a bit more.
I like to move around.
OK.
Here we go.
So Stuxnet's got to
spread on its own.
So Stuxnet uses seven
different distinct mechanisms
to spread to new computers.
So normally, a lot of
threats don't spread at all.
A lot threats will literally
come down into your computer.
They'll record keystrokes,
steal your credit card
numbers, your passport, and
so on, send it up, and so on.
But some threats will spread
from computer to computer.
We call them worms,
or attack tools
can be used to spread
between computers.
Stuxnet doesn't use
one technique, or two,
or three, or four.
It uses seven to spread.
So let's see how
it might spread.
So first of all, Stuxnet will
search for open drive shares
on different computers
in your network.
So if you share files
via drive shares,
it will enumerate
those drive shares,
enumerating the
computers on the network,
and it will copy itself
from one computer
to another over a driveshare,
and then install itself.
Stuxnet will attack a hole
in the Windows print spooler.
So basically, they
leverage a buffer overflow
in the Windows print spooler,
to basically send a shell code
over to the print spooler, and
then inject a copy of Stuxnet
onto a new computer.
So if you had a printer
driver, a print spooler running
on a computer that was available
over the network, guess what?
Stuxnet would use that
to spread as well.
Now, there's one supposition,
hypothetical, that in fact,
the two networks, the
air-gapped network,
where the centrifuges
were running,
and the research
network, might have been
connected by a shared printer.
And if that's the case,
that would be one way
in order to get onto
the air-gapped network.
But we don't know.
Now in addition to spreading
via these two mechanisms,
guess what?
Stuxnet also attacked
the hole in Windows RPC.
If you're not
familiar with RPC, RPC
stands for remote
procedure call.
This is a mechanism
to do remote function
calls between two computers.
In Stuxnet, leverage the
flaw of vulnerability
to get another type
of buffer overflow
to attack one computer
from another computer,
and then inject itself
into that computer.
So it did that as well.
So now, we're on three
different mechanisms.
This was an interesting one.
So the SIEMENS
software that we talked
about, that STEP7 Software,
it actually uses a database
called WinCC.
And WinCC is like a database,
standard database, like MySQL,
or Oracle, and so on.
What's that?
A commodity.
It's a database.
Now that databases,
as it turns out,
when you install the SIEMENS
software, at least in the past,
had a default password.
OK?
Big surprise.
And so, whoever
built Stuxnet knew
that the database used
by this SIEMENS software
had a default password.
And so what they
did was they said,
hey, try to log into that
database with the default
password, and see
if you can get in.
You never know.
And if you can, then
send some commands over
to then install Stuxnet
on that computer.
So basically, they log
in through a back door.
Or not back door, but
effectively a default password
in the database software used
by SIEMENS STEP7, and boom,
they were in as well.
So if that wasn't enough,
they did that as well.
And the other thing they
did-- how many people here
are familiar with Visual
Studio, obviously,
for software development?
So Visual Studio, you might
have a project file or solution,
which is a data
file that has all
the information about your
source files and so on,
all your dependencies.
Well, the SIEMENS
software that's
used to develop software
to run these PLCs,
to run your roller coaster, or
whatever, it has similar data
files, like solutions, and
projects, in Visual Studio.
And as it turns out, Stuxnet
will locate those SIEMENS data
files, and insert
a copy of itself
in the SIEMENS data
files, so if you
take those data files
and happen to copy them
to another computer,
then Stuxnet
will actually spread
through the data files,
and then autolaunch
into that computer.
OK?
So simply sharing your
Visual Studio projects--
not Visual Studio,
but the equivalent
of the SIEMENS
projects, data files,
will cause Stuxnet
to spread as well.
And so guess what?
That will help you
get in as well.
OK?
And if that's not enough,
because why would that
be enough, Stuxnet
also has a peer-to-peer
updating mechanism.
So let's imagine that every one
of these infections of Stuxnet
was not on a machine that's
connected to the internet,
except for one.
Let's just imagine
one of these machines
is connected to the
internet, and that Stuxnet
variant updates to Version
2.0 from Version 1.0.
OK?
Well, it will automatically
contact all of its buddies,
and then it will update
them to Version 2.0,
even if none of them
get to the internet.
That's pretty impressive.
Come on.
Now, I've only shown you, I
think, six different mechanism,
so let's just do number seven.
If the centrifuges are
air-gapped-- and frankly,
you can't spread over the
network to these things
if there's no printer
connected-- then
how does Stuxnet get on
that air-gapped network?
And the answer is, it also
spreads over USB drives,
because why not?
So if you stick a USB drive in
a Stuxnet infected computer,
it will automatically
infect that USB drive.
And then what it'll
do is when you
bring that USB drive over
to this other computer here,
which you would probably
do, because you want
to bring something from
the outside network
to the air-gapped
network, guess what?
That machine will
be infected as well.
And as it turns out, of
all these mechanisms used
to spread, six of these
attacks basically leveraged day
zero attacks.
Now, if you're not familiar
with what a day zero attack is,
imagine that there is some
flaw in your house lock?
OK?
Now, you didn't know there's
a flaw in your house lock.
Basically, there
happens to be a flaw
that if somebody sticks
some type of toothpick
and pushes just right,
they can open your door.
Open the lock.
A day zero flaw
is in a case where
you don't know that
that flaw exists
that somebody can exploit.
A non-day zero threat would
be one where, oh yeah,
we know that locks
can be picked,
and we know how it
can be done, and we
have to try to
safeguard against that.
Day zero are vulnerabilities
where we just don't even
know that there's this
vulnerability, this problem
with your technology.
So Stuxnet, six of the
approaches it used to spread,
leveraged day zero
vulnerabilities in order
to infiltrate new machines.
Now we're amazed when we see one
day zero vulnerability attack.
When we see six,
that's unbelievable.
So basically, again,
very impressive.
Nothing that's rocket science.
Nothing that's
out of this world.
But pretty impressive they
would put all this together.
Now, we just saw
how Stuxnet spreads.
So we know it can go
from machine to machine,
it can spread on thumb drives.
Very exciting.
Now, it has to then discover
the proper computers.
So Stuxnet, as it turns
out, is extremely picky.
You see there, we have the
slipper from Cinderella.
It has to fit just right on the
foot in order for Cinderella
to choose the right
person for the shoe.
But Stuxnet is very similar.
Stuxnet will only activate
its payload, which
we'll talk about,
when it's found
an exact match, an exact
match, of the computer
it wants to find.
So first of all, Stuxnet
looks that the Windows machine
that it's on is
running STEP7 Software.
So if it comes to
a machine, if it
happens to find
a machine, that's
not running the
STEP7 software, it
knows it might be on
the right network,
but it's certainly not
on the right machine
to attack centrifuges.
So it will basically
do nothing, and just
start spreading from that
machine to other machines.
So it basically might
hit your machine.
And it says, oh, there's
no STEP7 Software here.
I'm going to just
keep spreading.
But it won't do anything
bad to your machine.
So you would never
know it was there.
But once it finds that STEP7
Software, it gets excited.
What's it going to do?
Well, what it does
is it actually
checks the data files
in that computer
to see if that
computer is connected
to an S7-315 programmable
logic controller from SIEMENS.
So it's checking to see whether
the Windows computer is hooked
up to that PLC device,
that controller
that we talked about.
And it has to be
exactly that model.
If you're hooked up to
a different model device
from your Windows
computer running STEP7,
Stuxnet will do nothing at all.
So it's fingerprinting
the hardware
that's connected to
this Windows computer.
Now, as it turns out, this
PLC, the programmable logic
controller, must
then be connected to
at least00 it must be at
least six CP-342-5 network
modules from SIEMENS.
These network modules
are these routers
I talked about that
basically route the traffic.
So it's actually
fingerprint the PLC,
and it's fingerprinting
the number of routers
connected to the PLC.
And finally, it fingerprints
each network module.
Each router, then,
must be connected
to 31 Fararo Paya or Vacon
NX frequency converters.
These are the things that
convert wall frequency
to the faster frequencies.
OK?
Exactly 31 of those.
Now, what's
interesting is, if you
do the math, what you'll
find is Stuxnet verifies
that it discovered the PLC
that is controlling at least
155 total frequency converters.
If you multiply
it all out, there
has to be at least 155
total frequency converters.
And what we learned, not
recently, but a little while
ago, is that Iran's
Uranium Enrichment
Program, their cascade,
leveraged exactly 160
centrifuges.
So basically, this
is fingerprinting
all the components,
and also making
sure that there are 160
frequency converters, or 155
or more frequency converters,
that are controlling something.
Now, of course, they could be
controlling something other
than uranium enrichment--
we don't know--
but that's what
it's fingerprinting.
You wonder how they
figured that out.
How did they discover
exactly that configuration?
So there must have been somebody
on the inside giving them
this information.
But we don't know.
We don't know.
OK.
So now we know how Stuxnet
discovers the right computer.
It's going to spread
over and over and over
between computers, until it
finds just the right computer
that is connected to just
the right hardware, or just
the right number of
frequency converters.
It's happy as a clam right now.
And now, it gets
down to business.
And this is where things
get really interesting.
Now Stuxnet starts by
downloading malicious logic
onto the PLC hardware.
So what it does, it has a little
mini me, a little mini Stuxnet.
And it sends that mini
Stuxnet over the PLC.
It actually is a
separate module that
runs on the hardware of PLC.
Which, by the way,
is a different--
it's not Intel hardware.
It's a different
embedded microprocessor.
OK.
And what you
probably didn't know
is that Stuxnet, at
least to my knowledge,
is the first threat
that actually
spread on embedded platforms, as
well as on traditional Windows
PCs.
It has different code,
different instructions set,
different machine
language, everything,
that it's using for both of
these different platforms.
OK.
So that's pretty
impressive right there.
OK.
So now, they have a little bit
of logic running on the PLC
itself.
This controller, it actually
controls the operation
of all these centrifuges.
But they don't know that
they're centrifuges yet.
They think.
They think they're
centrifuge spinning systems.
But right now, all they know is
they got 155 different things
they're connected to.
So next, what Stuxnet does
is it measures the operating
speed of the
frequency converters
during their normal operation.
So what Stuxnet does is it
just sits there for 13 days.
It does not do
any damage at all.
It just sits there, and it
watches telemetry coming back
from these frequency
converters saying,
how fast are you spinning?
So as these frequency
converters are spinning,
they're sending
telemetry up to the PLC.
OK.
And Stuxnet is intercepting
that telemetry.
It has actually patched
code in the PLC,
so it has control
part-time, and it's
monitoring the
telemetry coming back
from these frequency
converters, saying
how fast they're spinning.
And it actually saves that data.
And it makes sure that the
motors are running between 807
hertz and 1,210 hertz.
Which, by the way, guess
what, is the frequency
range for making cotton candy.
No, I'm kidding.
For spinning
enrichment [INAUDIBLE].
So this is coincidentally
the frequency range
required to run centrifuges.
So it's monitoring and making
sure further that not only is
it connected to more
than 155 devices,
but those devices are
spinning really, really fast.
As it turns out, devices
spinning at that rate
are export-controlled
in the United States.
You can even export
them to other countries,
because they are only
used for one thing, which
is centrifuging,
enrichment of uranium.
And why would they do
the fingerprinting again?
Why further fingerprint to make
sure the frequencies are right?
Because Stuxnet wouldn't
want to take out a roller
coaster or something.
Because it could.
Because these devices could
be connected to potentially a
roller coaster.
So now, they know they're
running on the right device.
They measured for 13 days
exactly what was going on.
Pretty cool.
Now once it's sure that
it's on the right Windows
PC and the PLC, Stuxnet
begins its mischief.
What it does is it
ups the spin rate
from the defaults spin
rate of about 1,000 Hertz
to 1,410 Hertz.
And it takes about 15
minutes to do this.
In other words, you can't
just spin these tubes.
They're heavy.
They can't just spin all
of a sudden at 1,400 Hertz.
So it increases the speed, and
they go faster, and faster,
and faster.
And in fact, we don't think
they can actually reach
1,400 Hertz in 15 minutes.
They might reach around
1,300 and something Hertz.
They're not going
to probably reach
that, because they
couldn't spend that much
faster in that kind of time.
But it spins them up.
Spins them faster and faster.
So watch the gauge.
The gauge is going to go up.
It sends a command to all
those frequency conversions.
Say, spin faster.
Increase the frequency.
And they basically start
spinning up at a higher rate.
OK.
And then guess what?
After 15 minutes, it
goes back to normal.
Back to normal.
And guess what?
Stuxnet sleeps for 27
days after doing that.
It does nothing.
It does nothing else.
Sets it up to 1,400 Hertz,
or tries to, 15 minutes,
and then puts them back to
normal and back to sleep.
So imagine you're the guard.
You're sort of
walking the halls.
You're walking the halls.
All the stuff, everything
starts spinning
like a bunch of clothes washers,
or whatever, really fast.
And you're thinking,
what's going on?
Maybe I should hit
the big red button.
Who do I call?
And everything's normal again.
You're like, oh, I'm
not say anything.
I don't want to get killed.
I don't want have a false alarm.
So it sleeps again.
OK?
Now, after 27 days,
because it's very patient,
Stuxnet then slows the spin rate
down to 2 Hertz for 50 minutes.
So again, these things,
they were going really fast,
down in Hertz.
And all of a sudden, 27 days
later, they're like, [PUFFING].
Imagine how slow that would be.
And again, the guard's
looking around.
He's like, what's going on?
They're running around.
We have to fix this
thing, and so on.
Everything's crazy.
So it sends a command,
and it lowers that rate.
You can watch the dial
there, down to 2 Hertz.
Now, again does it
really get to 2 Hertz?
Probably it might
get to two hertz.
But I don't know,
because I wasn't there.
And guess what?
Stuxnet then goes back
to sleep for 27 days.
So imagine there's this
ghost in the machine.
And all of a sudden,
everything goes crazy.
And then when you
start looking into it,
everything goes back to normal,
and then you nothing happens,
and you're waiting for it.
And you're like, oh, there
must be some bug in our code.
You look at the code, and
there's nothing wrong.
And this is what's happening.
Now, Stuxnet repeats this
process over and over and over.
So God only knows how
many times it did this
with uranium just simply
looking and saying,
oh, what's going on?
We don't know.
OK.
Now here's a question.
Why would you push the
motors up to 1,410 Hertz?
As it turns out, 1,380 Hertz
is a resonance frequency.
Now, if you're not familiar
with a resonance frequency,
sometimes when you're driving
down the road on a bumpy road,
and the bumps are
sort of evenly spaced,
and the car starts vibrating
[BUZZING NOISE] over time,
that's a resonance frequency.
And as you get into
a resonance frequency
with uranium enrichment
tubes, guess what?
They start vibrating, and they
start vibrating violently,
and they will actually explode.
I haven't tried this at home.
But this is what we're told.
So basically, 1,380 Hertz
is a resonance frequency
that should cause
these tubes to explode.
So even if they don't
reach 1,410 Hertz,
if they get fast enough,
they could actually
cause a lot of damage, just
because the vibrations become
so, so strong.
Now, why reduce the
motors to 2 Hertz?
Anybody have an idea?
Not a resonance frequency.
It's just sort of like this.
It's not really exciting.
OK.
So why would you reduce
the motors to 2 Hertz?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CAREY NACHENBERG: Well,
the gas would mix,
but it'll start spinning
again for 27 days,
and it'll fix it up again.
I heard something about
a preschool, but I--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CAREY NACHENBERG:
Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
Oh, well, that's interesting.
Well, this is guess.
We don't know, but I think
you're on the right track.
So if you reduce it
to roughly 2 Hertz,
you're going to be
going really slow.
And if you think--
oops, hold on.
And if you think about
a top, what happens
when a top starts slowing down?
It begins to wobble.
So we think this would actually,
for prolonged periods of time,
would cause the centrifuges
to wobble on their axes,
and then basically
damage the bearings
and damage the base
of the centrifuge.
We don't know.
But this is what Stuxnet did.
OK.
Now, you might say, what about
Iranian fail-safe systems?
Right?
In other words,
the Iranians must
have been monitoring everything,
and all the red lights
must have been
going off, and you
have sirens going off when
the frequencies went too high.
So surely by now,
you're thinking
that the alarm bells
would have been ringing,
and that somebody would
have come running in.
It wouldn't have just been the
night guard who had seen this.
So maybe Stuxnet pulled
a "Mission Impossible."
You know, like "Mission
Impossible," where
they put the fake video
up in front of the camera,
so that basically, you couldn't
see what was really happening.
Maybe you did
something like this,
and you got the guy
falling down the stairs.
And the guy monitoring it is
like, oh, nothing's happening.
Everything looks fine.
And meanwhile, the
guy's following.
Maybe they did
that kind of thing.
Wouldn't that be great
if Stuxnet did that.
Well, guess what?
That's what Stuxnet did.
So it wasn't quite as exciting.
It wasn't actually
recording video,
because there was no video
involved in centrifuging.
OK?
But in fact, these facilities,
as we understand it,
do have watchdog systems
that are watching
to make sure the systems don't
go out of the right spin rates.
And they trigger a
shut down supposedly
if things go out of kilter.
But worry not stuck.
Stuxnet takes care of this.
And how does it do it?
Well, as I told you, Stuxnet
is recording telemetry
as the centrifuges run,
normally for 13 days, right?
So as these centrifuges
run, it's actually
recording normal behavior
that normal telemetry that's
coming up, and it stores it.
OK.
And as you can
see, that telemetry
is also going back to
the Windows system.
However, once Stuxnet
flips a switch
and starts changing
the frequency to say,
1,400 Hertz, as the bad data
is coming back, that says,
hey, I'm spinning
at 1,380 Hertz,
what Stuxnet sends to
the Windows computer
is the original recorded data of
the original 1,000 Hertz speed.
So watch the following.
If you look at the
dial-- OK, if you
look at the dial on
the screens, you'll
notice the dial will be
at about 1,400 Hertz,
because that's
where we're going.
That's what's really happening
with these centrifuges.
But if you look at the
dial on the Windows PC,
which shows what the Windows
monitoring software thinks
is happening, that's going
to be at still 1,000 Hertz.
So watch this.
So Stuxnet sends out the command
that says, spin really fast.
You can see that things
start spinning really fast.
However, Stuxnet's sending
back the green telemetry,
the original telemetry, back
to the monitoring system,
so it thinks that
nothing's wrong.
So in fact, it will not
trigger any alarm bells.
That's unbelievable.
I mean, come on, guys.
That's pretty impressive,
that it would do that.
OK?
But if gets more impressive.
As it turns out,
Stuxnet actually
disables the
emergency kill switch.
[LAUGHING]
So let's imagine that even
though the sirens are blaring,
you say, hey, wait a second,
these things are spinning.
They're like fast speed
at the laundromat.
Something's going wrong.
Maybe I should hit
that big red button.
Well, as it turns out,
that big red button's
connected to the PLC, but
it's connected digitally.
There's a wire, but
there's also a digital sort
of shut off that's connected
to that big red button.
At least, this is as
we understand it--
and it actually severs--
watch the little line there.
It actually severs-- come on.
Let's sever.
Sever.
OK.
It severs that digitally.
So you could hit that button
all you, playing whack-a-mole,
and things aren't going to
stop spinning really fast.
So, pretty impressive.
OK.
So they're hiding stuff with the
digital video camera sort of.
They're severing
the kill switch.
That's impressive.
Like, I can't make
this stuff up.
My book's not quite this
creative, but it's pretty good.
So what's amazing, though,
is Stuxnet evaded detection
for several years.
Right?
So it did all the things
we were talking about,
all while evading detection.
Now, how did it evade detection?
Well, it uses five distinct
mechanisms to conceal itself,
because one would not be
enough, two would not be enough.
So let's just go for
five, because why not?
So, number five Stuxnet
hides its own files
on affected drives, thumb
drives, using two rootkits.
It actually uses two
different root kits.
Now, you may not be familiar
with what a rootkit is,
but a rootkit is a
piece of software
whose only purpose
is to basically hide
other software in
a computer system.
So the root kit is
typically a driver,
although it doesn't always
need to be a driver,
and it runs, and it
will monitor access
as users use APIs to look
for files, like Find First,
Find Next, to enumerate files
on a file system, and so on.
And what Stuxnet will do is,
if it sees somebody trying
to enumerate its
files, it will say,
oh, these aren't the
droids you're looking for.
There's no files here.
It will actually hide the files.
It uses two different rootkids.
Now, let me show you what
this might look like.
And it's actually
really interesting.
So if you looked at a
Windows list of files,
it might be difficult
for you to see,
but you notice there are
three files on the bottom that
are a little different.
They're sort of with the
blue title bar there.
Those might be your legitimate
files, the files you actually
have on your thumb drive.
OK?
Those might be the
files you actually
have on your thumb drive.
The files on top, there's
a bunch of link files,
if I'm not mistaken,
those link files
are files that
are Stuxnet files.
These are actually
the files that Stuxnet
will put on the thumb
drive when it spreads.
So it actually puts a number
of different files on the thumb
drive.
Now, the moment you
stick that thumb
drive into a computer,
what will happen
is Stuxnet's going to copy the
top six files onto that thumb.
But if you look at this
thumb drive in Explorer,
you sort of say, what's
on this thumb drive,
at least on a Windows
computer, you're
going to see just
your three files.
In other words, it
will immediately
run through an exploit, as we'll
tell you about, its rootkit.
The rootkit will say, oh,
a thumb drive's installed.
Oh, my files are
on the thumb drive.
Oh, I'm going to hide my files.
So all you'll see are the
three files that are supposed
to be on your thumb drive.
Now you might ask,
how is it actually
causing a rootkit to run
the moment you stick a thumb
drive in?
So [INAUDIBLE] you could
stick this thumb drive
in a computer that is not
yet infected by Stuxnet,
and it will still
hide these files.
Pretty good.
So how does it do it?
Well, as it turns
out, these link
files at the top, which
are difficult to see,
but they're up there-- there's
one called the Copy of Copy
of Copy of Shortcut to Link.
So if you're not familiar
with what link file is,
a link file is a
file that you might
put on your desktop,
which basically contains
a location of an application.
So it might be, for instance,
a link to Word for Windows.
So when you double click on the
link, it runs Word for Windows
in its home directory,
so it can run normally.
It's basically a way of having
a shortcut to your applications.
That's what a link file is.
Now, as it turns out,
there was a vulnerability
in Windows, a bug,
so if you format
a link file a certain
way, basically, you
will buffer overflow
Windows, and crash Windows,
and cause your own
malicious software to run.
So what Stuxnet did
was it put a link
to file on this
thumb drive, along
with its own malicious file.
So in the temp files here,
you see that first file,
Tilde WTR4132.10?
That is a Stuxnet file,
as is the other temp file.
Those are the actual binaries
and machine code and so on
in Stuxnet.
But let's take the
first link file,
let's say, Copy of
Shortcut 2.link.
That file, when let's say
Windows XP at the time
would have parsed that file,
it would have had a buffer
overflow, that link file
would have taken control,
injected shell code, which
would have then launched
Stuxnet, which would have
then started hiding itself.
And then you would see these
files disappear immediately.
OK?
Now the question is, why would
there be multiple link files?
Anybody?
Different versions of the OS.
That's exactly right.
We have smart people here.
Wonder why?
It's Google, I guess.
That's right.
So basically, the
creators of Stuxnet
knew that this was
going be running
on Windows Vista, and
Windows XP, and Windows 7,
and so on, and Windows
2003 Server, and so on.
What they did was they
created a special link file
so that as Windows opened
these link files, one of them
would cause that
version of Windows
to crash, because each
crashed in a
different way and had
to be exploited with a different
type of link file formatted
in a different way.
So basically, they included
a different version
of the link file for every
different version of Windows
they wanted to target.
So whether you inserted this
thumb drive in Windows XP,
Windows 7, Windows 2003 Server,
whatever it happened to be,
boom, they would
immediately take control,
and compromise that computer
with a different export.
So they were prepared
for everything.
OK.
So that was the way
they hid themselves.
That was one of the
two rootkits they used.
Number four.
Stuxnet inhibits
different behaviors
in the presence of
different security products
to avoid detection.
So what do I mean by this?
Well, it might try to
spread in a certain way,
opening a certain type
of network connection up,
that might trigger a
particular security program.
Right?
OK.
So for instance, let's imagine
we had Symantec Endpoint
Protection.
That's our product, Symantec
Endpoint Protection.
Maybe Kaspersky
Internet Security,
McAfee Total Protection.
That's three different
security products.
As it turns out, actually,
at least our product
and McAfee's product are
export-controlled to Iran,
so they couldn't
even run in Iran.
But I'm using it as an example.
OK.
So what Stuxnet will
do, maybe Stuxnet
has four different
attacks it can launch
or something, or four
different ways of spreading,
although we learned
it was seven.
But I'm showing you four.
What Stuxnet might do is, in the
presence of Symantec Endpoint
Protection, it might
basically eliminate
two of the different
mechanisms from spreading,
because it would know those
would trigger the security
software.
So it just won't even do them.
And in the presence
of Kaspersky,
it would eliminate
different behaviors entirely
to prevent Kaspersky
from triggering.
Now in the case for
McAfee, of course,
it wouldn't have to eliminate
any behaviors at all,
because they probably
couldn't detect it anyway.
That was a joke.
They're a competitor.
I apologize.
That was very inappropriate.
I take that back.
It might eliminate
other behaviors.
That was very inappropriate.
It's now called Intel Security.
It's different.
I'm sure it's
perfectly effective.
OK.
[LAUGHING]
So number three.
Stuxnet completely deletes
itself from USB keys
after it's spread to
exactly three systems.
So Stuxnet keeps track of how
many systems it's spread to.
And once it's infected three
different systems, guess what?
It basically removes itself
from the thumb drive.
So if you were to look
at the thumb drive
on another machine,
or a Mac, or whatever,
it will look entirely clean.
Why did they choose three?
Somebody's lucky number.
I don't know.
That's sort of interesting.
Number two, Stuxnet's
authors digitally
signed it with stolen
digital certificates
to make it look
like it was created
by well-known companies.
Now, this is interesting.
I don't know how
many people know what
digital certificates are here.
Probably in this audience,
many do, but maybe
on the internet, of the
hundreds of thousands
of people that are going
to watch this and then buy
my book, let me tell you.
So sometimes, you'll see little
holograms, little holograms
on your credit cards.
Those are stamps
of authenticity,
and they help you identify--
or even on currency, right,
you'll see these little
strips and so on.
They help you identify
that it's not a fake.
Well, a digital certificate is
a digital equivalent of that.
And what you can do is
obtain a digital certificate
from a certificate authority.
And basically, what it is a
special cryptographic number
that helps you stamp
your software that says,
hey, this software
came from Microsoft,
or this software
came from Symantec,
came from Google.
OK.
And this is used to prove
that software has not
been tampered with.
You can stamp it, and
basically make sure
that it can't be
changed, or it can
be detected if it was changed.
And so, lots of software that
runs on Windows computers
is actually digitally signed.
And that, again,
helps Windows identify
that, oh, this actually
hasn't been tampered with.
It's from a particular
company, and you can find out
who that company is, and so on.
So what Stuxnet did is they
signed their driver files
with certificates from
two different companies,
one of which was RealTek.
Now, the two stolen certificates
were from RealTek and Jmicron.
These are two companies
that are based in Taiwan.
And as it turns out, they're
based in the same business
park.
They're about a kilometer away.
So you wonder, do the guys
who stole these certificate,
these basically digital
stamps of authenticity,
which are normally kept in
vaults-- in other words,
these things are very, very
valuable pieces of data,
because you can use them to
make software look like it
came from you.
I mean, imagine if somebody
sold Microsoft certificates,
and then made
software that looked
like it's coming from Microsoft,
but it was actually malicious.
That would be really bad.
OK?
That would call into
question the safety
of all software from
Microsoft, for instance,
or other companies.
Don't choke.
OK.
I'm sorry.
It's OK.
So these digital
stamps, if you will,
are actually stored
typically in vaults,
they're in HSMs, basically
hardware security modules
or machines.
They're very well-protected.
So you wonder how the
people who built Stuxnet
got these certificates.
Maybe they did
something like that.
I don't.
But anyway, this didn't trigger
Windows, because Stuxnet
basically was signed with
legitimate certificate
stamps of authenticity
as if they
came from legitimate
Taiwanese vendors.
Number one, Stuxnet
conceals its malicious code,
it's changes to the PLC.
So as I told you,
Stuxnet injects itself
onto that programmable
logic controller,
that device that controls
the centrifuges, right?
And again, it's doing so-- it's
actually not replacing code,
it's actually integrating
with the original code.
They actually knew what the
original code looked like,
and they patched the PLC
code that was running
the centrifuges on that PLC.
OK.
So what if an operator--
not an operator--
a programmer wanted to
look and say, well, what's
going on with our code?
We better take a look at
the code running on the PLC,
and make sure that
it hasn't changed.
It hasn't been tampered with.
Maybe there's somebody trying
to tamper with this code.
So what Stuxnet they did
was is it actually concealed
those changes.
So if you were to pull those
changes off the PLC and say,
tell me the active
state of the PLC.
What instructions are running?
What you would see
on the Windows screen
was, during normal operations,
spin at 1,000 Hertz.
And in case of
emergency, spin down.
Which is exactly
what you should see.
You'd see real instructions, The
machine language instructions.
That's what you should see.
But on the PLC, what
you would actually
have would be during normal
operations spin at 1,400 Hertz.
In the case of emergency,
ignore operator commands.
So it actually, what it would do
is as-- on the Windows machine,
as you would view the
instructions on the PLC,
it would watch them
coming over the wire,
intercept them before they
would be rendered on the screen,
remove itself from the
original instructions,
showing only the
original instructions.
And if you were to replace
the instructions on the PLC
with a new version
of the software
that it could integrate
with, it would
actually on the fly, as it
was being written to the PLC,
reintegrate in.
Pretty good.
All right.
So the question now is,
did Stuxnet succeed?
Now, you know what it
did, and how it spread,
and how it detected whether
it was on the right machines,
and how it hid itself.
It's pretty exciting.
So based on some clever
engineering, and some basically
deals with certain
people around the world,
we have some really
interesting data.
What we did was we found
out that Stuxnet contacts
two different
command and control
servers in order to get
commands from its masters.
Now, what's a command
and control server?
It's a computer on the
internet that a piece
of malicious
software can contact,
and that computer
and the internet
is controlled by the attacker.
So basically, the attacker
can put a new command saying,
hey, do this, or update
yourself to this, or whatever.
It's on the computer.
And every copy of Stuxnet
will connect to that server
and say, what should I do?
Is there anything new?
Should I update myself?
Is there a command
you have for me?
So those two servers were
located in Asia and in Europe.
And one was called
www.todaysfootball.com.
The other one was called
www.mypremierefootball.com.
So these command
and control servers
are running in
foreign ISP hardware.
They're just running on
servers somewhere else.
And working with domain
registrars, which
are the guys that control
the www.symantec.com
mapping to an IP address,
if that makes sense
to you, what we
did was we rerouted
all traffic going to these
two websites to Symantec.
So every copy of
Stuxnet that was
trying to go to those two
servers in Asia and Europe
instead was redirected to
Symantec Corporation, world
leaders in computer security.
OK.
Little plug there.
Now, I'm really supposed
to be plugging my book,
but I'm sure people
from Symantec
will be watching this video.
And If you really want to go and
help people around the world,
and you don't want to just sell
ads, please come and join us.
[LAUGHING]
I'm sorry.
I use your products.
I'm very happy with them.
OK, let's go.
OK.
So as Stuxnet spreads between
computers, as it turns out.
So first of all, it contacts
these command and control
servers.
And we took control of these
command and control servers,
so we actually could monitor
where every [INAUDIBLE]
at Stuxnet was.
The other point is that Stuxnet
spreads between computers.
As it spreads, it
actually keeps a log.
It actually keeps
a notch on its belt
every time it visits a computer,
because maybe it wants to brag.
I don't know.
But anyway, it tracks every
computer it's ever been to,
and we can look at
these logs in order
to see exactly where it's been.
Which IP addresses, which
machines, and so on.
So what do I mean by well?
Well, imagine we have a
bunch of machines here.
As Stuxnet reaches a machine,
it will infect the machine,
but it will also keep the IP
address of the machine it just
attacked.
And it will actually add that
to a log inside the threat.
So the second copy of
the threat as it spreads
to another computer
will actually
have two items in
its log, and so on.
And so, every copy
actually had a history
of every machine it's been to.
So this allows you to figure
out exactly who is impacted,
where they were, and so on.
And that actually also
helped us get information.
So it has a visited list,
or a little notch system.
OK.
So based on this
information, we found
that there were three
initial attack waves.
There were, to my
knowledge, if I
recall correctly, five
different victims that
were attacked initially.
That were the seed infections,
the generation zero infections.
Now these five different
victims were not
people involved in the
Iranian Enrichment Program
to our knowledge.
They were actually
subcontractors
to the Iranian
military that actually
worked with them
in order to help
them install these systems.
So whoever infected
them actually
infected the contractors,
and then the contractors,
either inadvertently or
intentionally, brought it in.
And you can see the waves.
You can also see the compile
time versus infection time,
and you can see
that in some cases,
these things were
released within hours
of actually being compiled.
In other cases, they sat on
them and actually held them
for a long time.
So when we say
infection time, that's
a first discovery
of an infection.
And you can see the
days to infect there.
And here are some graphs.
This is, again,
from the information
where Stuxnet keeps a log
of every machine it visits.
You can see every dot
is a Stuxnet infection.
And you can see if there's a
connection between two dots,
it means that one
machine was infected,
and then the infection
spread to a second machine.
And here's the geographic
distribution of infections,
to give you an idea.
Iran was primarily hit, but
Indonesia, India, and so on
were also hit.
Now this, again, doesn't mean
that it was actually disrupting
their centrifuge programs,
because they almost certainly
had different setups
for their enrichment
in these other countries.
But it certainly
actually visited
computers in those countries.
And here, we see distribution
of infected systems
with SIEMENS software.
So you can see,
these are systems
that actually got to where it
said, oh, I'm getting close.
I'm reporting back
that I actually
found something interesting.
Because it's telling
that she was all
set up so that the masters of
Stuxnet would know, oh, maybe
there are other things
we don't know about.
Maybe this is spreading to
systems we didn't expect.
OK.
So did Stuxnet succeed?
Well, indications are that
it did, at least partially.
Symantec telemetry indicates
that rather than directly,
as I told you, trying
to infiltrate Natanz,
they did go through
subcontractors,
industrial companies.
And then they unknowingly
ferried the infections in.
And the Institute for Science
and International Security
writes that it's
increasingly accepted
that in a 2009, early in
2010, Stuxnet destroyed
around 1,000 centrifuges.
[INAUDIBLE] about 9,000.
And it probably caused them
a great deal disruption.
In other words, you
would expect that they
were trying to figure
out what was going on.
Did they have moles?
Did they have insiders?
Were there spies?
What was going on?
So it may have actually
done a great deal of good.
Now finally, who did it.
You should probably
have some idea.
You might have heard, but just
in case you haven't, there's
some very interesting clues.
First of all, as it turns out,
when Stuxnet affects a machine,
it actually creates a
setting on the machine.
Because one thing that
malware does is it
doesn't want to
reinfect computers.
If a malware file
is automatically
spreading from
computer to computer,
it might go from this
computer to this computer.
But then once it gets
to this computer,
it's going to go
back to this computer
and back to this computer.
It'll go back and forth.
And you might have 100 copies
of the malware process running
on a computer if you
don't check for that.
So what Stuxnet does is the
moment it gets on a computer,
it sets a setting
with this number.
OK?
And if this - is present,
then a new copy of Stuxnet
will not run, because it knows,
oh, Stuxnet's already here.
I don't want to run.
Now as it turns out, if
you look up this number,
and you're a conspiracy
theorist, what you'll find
is on Wikipedia,
which we know always
holds the truth, that
according to Wikipedia,
on May 9, 1979, which
might be 19790509,
Habib Elghanian was
executed by a firing squad
in Tehran, sending shockwaves
through the closingly-knit
Iranian Jewish community.
He was the first Jew and
one of the first civilians
to be executed by the
newly Islamic government.
This prompted the mass exodus of
the once 100,000-member strong
Jewish community of Iran,
which continues to this day.
We don't know if
this is related,
but it's certainly exciting.
I've also heard people tell
me that that was a new moon.
There's all kinds
of crazy things
that might be associated.
But there's
something else that's
really interesting that
also leads us to believe
that Israel might be involved.
Now, as many of you know, when
you compile an executable file
with Visual Studio,
Visual Studio
will put a date
stamp in the header
of the file, a date and
time stamp which says
when the file was compiled.
It was compiled January 5, 3:00
AM, whatever it happens to be.
And we knew about
this date stamp.
I've known about
I've been analyzing
Windows malware for years.
But as it turns out, Visual
Studio-- and by the way,
this date stamp is in GMT.
It's in GMT, or
Greenwich Mean Time.
As it turns out, Visual Studio
also insert a second date stamp
into the file in a
different place in the file.
I never knew this, but it does.
And it inserts a second
date stamp and time stamp
in local time.
And what we found was
that on the sample,
the sample had a
GMT of 4:31, and it
had a local time 6:31, which
means two hours east of GMT.
Now, if you can guess
all of the countries that
are two hours east of GMT, I'll
tell you what it is, Jamaica.
OK?
Jamaica really was
responsible for Stuxnet.
If you do the math,
this is GMT plus two,
which happens to be the region
where Israel is located.
Now as we now know,
I think we now
have an idea that
this was actually
a joint program between the
United States and Israel.
But this is an
interesting indicator.
It just shows you
that forensic analysis
can reveal all kinds
of interesting things.
So to conclude, and
then I'll take questions
as long as you like, Stuxnet has
signaled the fundamental shift
in the malware space.
And I don't say this
because, again, there
was some rocket science
or some fundamentally
new alien technology.
They showed that physical
systems can be disrupted
by virtual components.
Cyber warfare is feasible.
And unfortunately,
the same technique
can be used to attack other
physical and virtual systems.
So this is just the beginning.
We will probably
see more of this.
The good thing is,
is that-- I don't
know if it's good or
bad-- but espionage
is far more likely than
actual physical disruption.
Because physical
disruption is an act
of war in some sense-- right?
You're disrupting a system.
You might cause death.
You might cause all
kinds of problems,
whereas espionage, which is
most of what happens today,
just goes on.
You don't really know
what was affected.
You don't know
who really did it.
So there's a lot
more espionage now,
but we will see more,
almost certainly more,
physical disruption
in the future.
And that brings me to
my final, final topic.
So if you want to find out
how Iran gets even, and tries
to harm the United
States, consider
reading my new techno thriller.
There's a couple reviews.
I'll just leave
them on the screen.
Kirkus Reviews, by the way,
if you're not familiar,
is a reviewing company
like Publisher's Weekly.
It was a very nice review.
I did have to pay them for that.
I did have to bribe
the reviewer as well.
I'm kidding.
That's a joke.
I didn't give any bribes.
But anyway, our book has been
receiving a reasonable reviews.
And as I said, I'm donating
all proceeds to charities.
And if you found my
talk entertaining,
the book is sort of like that.
Sort of goofy, sort of exciting,
computers do get destroyed,
people get destroyed.
It's very exciting.
And you'll help underserved
children and veterans.
So find out more in on
florentinedeception.com.
And now, I'll take questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE:So I had two quick
questions about those details.
You said that after
infecting three machines,
Stuxnet wiped all trace
off the thumb drive?
CAREY NACHENBERG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: How did it
prevent reinfection
when it got plugged into one of
the other two computers again?
CAREY NACHENBERG: Good question.
I am actually not aware of
how to prevent a reinfection.
There's a couple
ways it could do.
It could actually leave, for
instance, a little artifact
in the directory
structure that would
be basically an identifiable.
But I'm not sure if it did.
It may have been reinfected
on a subsequent insertion
into another computer
that was infected.
AUDIENCE: And when you
redirected traffic for command
and control, did you
man in the middle,
or did you completely disrupt
Stuxnet's command and control?
CAREY NACHENBERG:
So, good question.
So the question was, when we
redirected all the traffic
from the thousands
of Stuxnet infections
to their command
and control servers,
we took control of the
servers, and we basically,
obviously, did not
send any commands,
and we basically
completely cut it off
from its original
masters, whoever that was.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was kind of surprised to
hear that they were actually
talking back to the
command and control center.
I mean, they went
through so many efforts
to not be discovered,
and then they just
ping some random
server on the internet?
I don't know.
I guess my question is,
is that something common
for these kind of things to do?
CAREY NACHENBERG: Yes.
Most or many threats will ping
command and control servers.
Actually, lots of
threats will ping Google.
And they do so just to
see if they actually
have internet
connectivity first,
because that's sort of
a very easy thing to do.
So this is a typical approach.
And if you look at
the typical company,
typical large enterprise,
or small company,
they have no idea what's going
on with on their network,
and what connections are being
made, and what's legitimate,
and what's not.
So that type of
connection, first of all,
would have been blocked in
an air-gapped network anyway,
and it would have
never been seen.
OK?
Because nobody has the time
to look at all firewall
log, and so on.
And second of all, it
just would blend in
with all the rest of
the traffic, because you
have literally millions
of connections per day
and per hour.
AUDIENCE: Was the payload
in the case encrypted?
Or was it just plain text?
CAREY NACHENBERG: Was
the payload encrypted?
I'm certain it was.
I don't know the details.
I'd have to find out.
If yoU send me an email
afterwards, I'll tell you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for coming today.
You mentioned, explain why
the frequencies were chosen,
versus [INAUDIBLE].
Do you have a theory of
why 13 days was chosen
as the initial monitored
period, or 27 days
was chosen as the
downtime to be normal?
CAREY NACHENBERG: I don't.
I don't have any theories.
I could talk to our
team and find out
if they have any
thoughts on that.
But I haven't heard anything
about that, frankly.
It may have been to just to
dispel any sort of suspicion,
because oh, it must have
been a glitch or something.
But I don't really know,
to be honest with you.
I know the significance
of those days.
Please?
AUDIENCE: Two quick questions.
First one, did you guys ever get
a hold of the actual executable
program, or did you just
determine all this information
from the command and
control interception?
CAREY NACHENBERG: Good question.
OK.
So we actually obtained many
copies of the executable.
Because remember, every
copy of the executable's
a little different, because
they're all customized
with where they visited.
Our team reverse
engineered from basically
down to every instruction we
could find, including reverse
engineering the payload for the
TLC, which required us to go
and reverse engineer the
machine language for the PLC,
because that wasn't documented.
So [INAUDIBLE] every
last bit, and I
was going to say something else.
One interesting thing
is once my colleagues,
who work in our
anti-malware analysis lab
realized what was
happening-- and it required,
by the way-- we didn't discover
this the 1,400 Hertz thing
right away.
We actually had to post
a blog entry saying, hey,
we found this malware.
It's obviously doing
some modification
of industrial control hardware.
But we don't know
what it is, and we
don't know what type of
system it's controlling,
so we posted a blog.
And somebody contacted
us and said, hey,
by the way, that
number that you posted
is actually the identification
of a frequency converter
of this particular type.
We looked it up, realized
that it was actually
a centrifuge control
frequency converter.
And then the next
day, my coworker
started looking under
his car for bombs.
[LAUGHING]
I'm serious.
I'm very serious.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Second question.
What could have Iran done
to help prevent this attack?
Or what are things--
I guess if Stuxnet
went to all this
trouble to do this, what
are some of the steps
that they could have
done to further prevent it?
CAREY NACHENBERG: So that's
a really good question.
What I would say
is that it would
be very difficult on
a Windows computer
to prevent something
like this type of attack.
You could run effectively what's
called white listing software.
And what white
listing software does
is it specifies that only the
following software can be run,
and nothing else outside
of this list of software
can be executed.
OK.
Not that I'm telling Iran
how to solve their problems,
but that's what
corporations would do.
That's a very difficult thing
to do, because on typical PCs,
software's updating
itself constantly,
you get new versions
of software.
If that software's
not on the white list,
then you end up having
a denial of service,
and the software stops running,
because the white list says,
oh, you're not on the white
list, and you'll be blocked.
So it's very
difficult to do that.
Ultimately, what you need
is a change in the platform.
In other words, you need to
go to an Android or iOS model,
where you have
containerization, software
can't get out of its
little bubble, and so on.
That's a much safer model than
the traditional Windows model.
The problem is there's hundreds
of millions of Windows programs
that assume no
containerization, and that
are not vetted, and so on.
So it's very, very
difficult to prevent this.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CAREY NACHENBERG:
You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was wondering if you
could speak to any
what you saw as maybe
updates in the various
versions of Stuxnet.
You said it was
self-updating, and maybe they
changed-- I don't know
if you saw them change
the configurations
they were targeting,
or narrow down somehow?
CAREY NACHENBERG: I'll
have to plead ignorance.
Unfortunately, yes.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for a great talk.
CAREY NACHENBERG: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Did the command and
control, were those owned,
or the domain names were bought
by some like, [INAUDIBLE]?
CAREY NACHENBERG:
My understanding
is that they were
basically provisioned just
for this purpose,
is my understanding.
They were not owned.
In other words, they were
not legitimate websites
that were compromised
in order to do this.
AUDIENCE: But we couldn't figure
out who purchased the domains
and work that back?
CAREY NACHENBERG:
I remember hearing,
but I don't remember
the details.
I don't remember exactly
how they were registered.
Obviously, they were
not registered to Joe
in Israel or something.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: If the
target machines were
it not connected directly
to the internet, how
did they phone home?
CAREY NACHENBERG:
So in those cases,
they would not phone home.
And what would have
to happen would
be that, for instance,
the research network,
you might get a new version
that did phone home,
get a new infection, and
then, for instance, even
affect the thumb drive.
You bring that thumb drive in.
2.0, version 2.0 of the
threat would override
version 1.0, and so on.
But yeah, in the
air-gapped network,
there would be no phone home.
AUDIENCE: So the phone home
was to upgrade the version
CAREY NACHENBERG: Yes.
To upgrade versions.
Also, to send telemetry back.
In other words, are you running?
Where are you running?
Are you running on a machine
that's running STEP7 software?
So it's giving visibility
as much as it's taking--
AUDIENCE: But if it
was running a machine--
CAREY NACHENBERG: Say it again.
AUDIENCE: If it was running on
its target machine, that's--
CAREY NACHENBERG: Then
it could not talk back.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: But that's the only--
CAREY NACHENBERG:
No, because remember,
when you're building centrifuge
software that runs centrifuges,
you're not doing it right
next to the centrifuge
here necessarily.
You're building it in a lab.
You're writing your code.
You might have a test
system or whatever,
and then you're bringing
that into the enrichment.
So these systems on
the research network,
where they were
doing the coding,
we believe were
connected to internet.
AUDIENCE: So how did
Symantec get involved
in researching Stuxnet?
Did it just come
through one day.
Hello, you've got another virus.
CAREY NACHENBERG:
Great question.
So how did we get involved
with researching Stuxnet?
So it's actually
a two-part answer.
The first part is
that we received
a copy of Stuxnet
months, if not maybe
a year, earlier than when we
started actually analyzing it.
We have 99.9% of
malware analysis
is done via automated systems.
So Stuxnet came in
from some customer.
I don't know who it was.
I don't remember.
We could find out, but
I can't tell you anyway.
Came in him from customer, and
our automated analysis system
said, oh, this is definitely
some type of malware,
and we fingerprinted that
version that we found.
OK?
We had protection for at
least some variant of Stuxnet,
I don't know, six
months, a year, earlier.
OK?
But we didn't know what it was.
And by the way, there are
multiple variants, and so on,
so that was just
one of the variants.
Fast forward to six
months a year later,
somebody contacted
us, because they
had noticed-- they
had done some analysis
and noticed that this used
a day zero vulnerability.
It exploited a day
zero vulnerability.
And they said, hey,
this is unusual.
Because when we
see that, we know
there's nation state or
organized crime involved.
It's not something regular.
And then we started
analyzing it.
We pulled up the
sample, which we had,
and we said, oh, we
fingerprint for that.
Let's look at it.
We looked at the samples, and
we realized that, in fact,
this was far more, and it was
months of time of analysis
to then realize what it was.
So really, two ways.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So given that this
was capable of being infected
on something so
sensitive, and that we
have lots of similar technology,
like controlling probably
very important things
in our own country,
in the grand scheme of
things, how screwed are
with the current
state of ability
to manipulate physical
devices, or maybe
even like military devices
using this type of attack?
CAREY NACHENBERG:
Tesla's [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
That's a good question.
So what I would say is
that, again, it's fortunate
that cyber warfare-- actually,
sort of kinetic modifications
through software--
are rare, because they
are perceived as acts of war.
Because if you talk
any security expert,
they can tell you five different
ways that you could really
cause destruction.
If you read my novel,
what you'll find out
is-- "The Florentine Deception,"
available in all major formats.
In my novel, I actually
propose a mechanism, which
is entirely feasible, that
would potentially take out
the entire hardware
infrastructure of the United
States, or any country that
would want to be targeted.
Permanent damage to that.
You literally would have to
replace the motherboards and so
on.
OK.
So it's totally feasible.
And I don't think we're seeing
it, because we would then
go and have a major military
intervention, and the people
who did that would
be in real trouble.
So there's no
technological reason
why we haven't seen
this, I would say.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CAREY NACHENBERG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
It's me again.
So you said you
redirected the traffic
from the command and control.
You kind of glossed over--
was that a DNS hijack,
or was that a--
CAREY NACHENBERG: So we
went to the Registrars.
The Registrar is a company
that actually basically takes
a website name like
myfootball.com,
mypremierefootball.com,
and associates with an IP
address on the internet OK.
And this is just for
the people in audience
who don't know this.
And so, what we did was
he said, hey, Registrar,
we know that this server,
myfootball.com, this IP address
is bad.
So we said, take that
domain, myfootball.com,
or mypremierefootball.com,
and to instead of this IP
address on the server, send
it to Symantec over here.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So the next question is,
who authorized Symantec
specifically to be able
to [INAUDIBLE] DNS?
CAREY NACHENBERG: We
talked to the Registrar,
so the Registrar made the
decision based on the evidence
that we provided them.
That was their decision to give
us that command and control
traffic.
Please?
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned that when
you see a day zero, like
a sophisticated day zero
vulnerability as part
of a malware packet,
that you assume it's
nation state or military.
When you saw Stuxnet and
realized it was there,
are there like, folks in the US
security structure that you go
talk to think about
maybe, you shouldn't
be looking at it further,
or spreading it differently?
CAREY NACHENBERG: So it's
an interesting question.
In other words, the question
is more generally, I think,
what is our role?
Is our role to defend any
particular nation state,
or make sure that we sort
of turn the other way?
First of all,
attribution is extremely
difficult with these things.
It's impossible to know
who built what and how.
In fact, today, we still don't
really know that for sure.
The way we look at it is, we
will protect our customers
no matter what country
they're in a matter,
no matter what
nationality they are.
We will protect
them from threats.
And so, we don't
go and say, hey,
do you think we detect
this, government?
We just say, look,
this is a threat.
We're gong to build protection
for it and do our best.
That's just the way we operate.
And frankly, if that happens
to damage a particular nation
state or not that's par
for the course for them.
They got to deal
with that anyway.
And as you saw,
they took mechanisms
to try to evade
security software.
And by the way, there are
many security products.
If we were to say,
hey, we're going
to go and sort of turn
our head the other way,
people would choose
other products.
So we basically protect our
customers wherever they are.
And of course, we're
export-controlled to Iran,
as I said, so we wouldn't have
worried about Iran anyway,
as it turns out.
OK.
We'll, I'll be staying
for lunch, so if you
want to ask another question.
[APPLAUSE]